pop
[Musique]
oui
à
l'union
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
février 1828 dans une petite île battue
par les vents
mais un écrivain dont l'oeuvre
extraordinaire traduite en plus de cent
seize langues restent encore aujourd'hui
celle qui le plus lu dans le monde
entier il s'appelait jules verne avril
1926 un écrivain américain décide de
créer une revue dans laquelle il
publiera des textes de prophétie
scientifique dit il et comme il n'est
guère satisfait de ce terme
ils vont créer un autre qui fera
littéralement fortune science-fiction
avril 1979 pour la première fois en
europe et créer un magazine de
télévision entièrement consacrée à la
science fiction temps x eh bien oui
temps x et donc votre magazine le
magazine de tous ceux qui aiment et
connaissent la science fiction bien sûr
mais également de tous ceux qui
s'intéressant à l'avenir souhaitant
découvrir certains aspects que sera
notre monde demain telle est la question
que se posent les auteurs de science
fiction et c'est de cette réponse que
découle toute la science fiction c'est à
dire une approche du futur par le veau
de l'imaginaire et avant tout par la
voie du romain depuis jules verne tenez
vous bien à plus de 50 milles textes ont
été publiés
et puis il ya bien sûr le cinéma qui n'a
pas entendu parler ou vu des films comme
rencontre du troisième type et ou encore
la guerre des étoiles
et puis il y a encore la bande dessinée
la musique le cinéma le théâtre même la
sculpture de science fiction
bref on peut dire aujourd'hui que la
science fiction est bel et bien partout
alors partons à la découverte à la
découverte de ce nouveau et passionnant
domaine de la culture où tout est
possible et avant tout commençons par
l'actualité
chaque semaine nous vous présenterons
des informations des films des ouvrages
que nous sélectionnons exprès pour vous
et qui nous paraîtront les plus
intéressants d'autre part dans leurs
rubriques temps x à la une nous mettrons
en valeur chaque fois un événement
particulièrement important dans le champ
de la science fiction
il pourra s'agir bien sûr d'ouvragé il
pourra s'agir également de tout autre
chose à la une de temps x cette semaine
andré ruellan l'auteur de science
fiction bien connu et enfin pour tous
ceux qui veulent rêver au futur eh bien
eh bien nous ferons une découverte des
grands thèmes de science fiction
et cette fois-ci nous commencerons par
le voyage dans les
parce que nous mettrons en question tout
à l'heure en compagnie du physicien jean
pierre petit voilà c'est comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure à un voyage que
nous vous invitons à un fabuleux voyage
qui nous mènera très loin jusqu'aux
frontières du possible
alors attention nous ne sommes plus en
1979 temps x vous souhaite la bienvenue
dans l'avenir et bien pour nous l'avenir
commence tout de suite et pour ce
premier plateau consacré à l'actualité
j'aimerais vous présenter cette grande
dame qu'est la science fiction d'abord à
travers un guide qui vient de sortir aux
éditions denoël dans la collection
présente du futur il s'intitule
catalogue des armes et cycles de la
science fiction il est signé standard
est alors qu'est ce que vous allez
trouver dans ce guide est bien
énormément de choses d'abord des
indications concernant les auteurs
ensuite vous pourrez savoir de quoi est
fait la science-fiction quels sont les
thèmes qu'elle aborde vous y trouverez
également des résumés des meilleurs
titres parus jusqu'à l'heure en fait
après avoir lu ce livre vous ne viendrez
un véritable spécialiste
et puis si toutefois vous préféré
aborder la science fiction par la voie
du rhum en vous divertissant et bien je
vous propose un livre qui vient de
paraître aux éditions presses pocket
dans la collection le livre d'or de la
science fiction
c'est un recueil d'excellentes nouvelles
consacrée à l'auteur américain robert
silverberg alors imaginez un peu que
dans un futur pas très éloigné vous
soyez soigné par un ordinateur ce sont
eux qui désormais dans ce monde-là
remplacent les psychiatres
tout va bien jusqu'au jour où
l'ordinateur se mettent à derrière son
tour alors que se passe-t-il
et bien la réponse est dans le livre de
silverberg ainsi que d'autres choses
tout aussi passionnante
puis enfin si c'est bien possible vous
avez envie de vivre pleinement
l'aventuré la science fiction et bien à
ce moment là n'hésitez pas rendez vous
au festival international de la science
fiction qui se tiendra du 2 au 8 mai à m
vous y retrouverez des auteurs vous
verrez énormément de films et ma foi si
vous ne sortez pas de là avec les
connaissances de véritables spécialistes
et que vous êtes réfractaire à toute la
culture de science fiction maintenant
michel azot j'aimerais me tourner vers
toi puisque nous avons parlé de musique
de science fiction et que tu seras notre
spécialiste à temps x est ce que tu
pourrais nous ordonner très rapidement
une
définition définir la musique de science
fiction me paraît assez difficile
actuellement mais disons qu'il ya une
musique qui évoque l'espace qui évoque
la technologie par les moyens qu'elle
met en oeuvre la stéréophonie la
spatialisation du son le synthétiseur et
certains musiciens commencent dès
maintenant faire appel des thèmes de
science fiction dans leurs oeuvres
il apparaît de plus en plus aujourd'hui
alors il en paraît de plus en plus parce
que la science fiction c'est aussi un
excellent support de vente aussi bien
pour certaines marques de pantalons que
pur délice
pourquoi pas merci michel nous te
retrouveront dans les semaines suivantes
et puisque nous sommes dans le domaine
de l'art et bien restons-y francis tu
seras notre spécialiste haras temps x
comment pourra plus au fil des semaines
circonscrit les limites de cet art de
science fiction
je crois qu'il faut tracer très
précisément les frontières de l'art de
science fiction ne pas le confondre ni
avec le surréalisme ni avec l'art
fantastique l'art de science-fiction
s'appuie sur la technologie sa rencontre
avec l'infini mais bien sûr avec l'homme
avec la peinture aujourd'hui nous allons
voyager dans l'espace et je vous
conseille de bien attacher vos ceintures
car notre vitesse sera presque la
vitesse de la lumière
depuis i cor l'homme rêve à l'espace et
essaye de s'y élever pas atteint parfois
avec la plus grande fantaisie
[Musique]
plus souvent en transposant son
quotidien dans la valse ininterrompue de
ce carrousel étrange
de ses fulgurants cigare naïvement
aérodynamique qui finalement ne
conduiront vers d'autres galaxies
[Musique]
chris fausses et le peintre de cette
épopée intergalactique
le david de l'imaginaire spatiale qui
nous montre l'infiniment petit dans
l'infiniment grand le savoir dans le
pouvoir met en scène l'opéra des mondes
j'ai collé et mcall une technique issue
de la nasa
[Musique]
dans la paix de l'esprit
les épaves glisseront pour l'éternité
des images plutôt mouvementée vous en
conviendrez
mais au fond tant que la violence reste
dans l'espace cela ne nous concerne
guère
du moins pas encore en revanche lorsque
cette violence se fait sentir
aujourd'hui sur terre cela devient de
beaucoup plus inquiétant tel est le
sujet que nous allons aborder cette
semaine avec andré ruellan dans le temps
x et la une andré ruel vous êtes bien
connu de tous les amateurs de science
fiction française pour les nombreux
livres vous avez publié jusqu'ici les
invités de temps x aujourd'hui pour un
livre que vous venez de publier aux
éditions jean claude lattès temps la
collection titre sf et pour un pour un
film dont vous êtes le scénariste le
dernier film d'alain jessua et toutes
ces deux oeuvres portent le titre
les chiens alors tout de suite cette
question andré avellin comment peut-on
faire une histoire de science-fiction
avec les chiens qui sont dit-on le
meilleur ami de l'homme
de toute façon pour faire une histoire
de science-fiction avec
des amis ou des ennemis de l'homme et on
peut faire de la science fiction avec
absolument n'importe quoi la manière d'
arranger les éléments étant la seule
importante est ce que la violence serait
un des thèmes d'apparat de la science
fiction aujourd'hui je pense que la
violence fait partie de n'importe quelle
sorte de formes d'expression que ce soit
le cinéma la littérature et à
l'intérieur de ses formes y compris la
science fiction mais je crois qu'on
attire énormément l'attention sur la
violences actuelles comme si tous
s'aggravait d'année en année à la vérité
si on jette un coup d'oeil sur ce qui
s'est passé selon les chiffres que l'on
a en les tenant en main sur l'année 1643
on apprendra qu'il y a eu dans paris qui
à l'époque comptait deux cent mille
habitants environ trois cent soixante
dix neuf assassinats comme paris compte
actuellement huit millions d'habitants
ça nous mènerait à environ 15000
assassinat pour l'année 78 8 mois
sénégal jouissant ce qui montre bien que
si on attire tellement l'attention sur
la violences actuellement on la tire
peut-être pas suffisamment l'attention
sur ce que la violence peut provoquer
comme contre violence c'est à dire
l'autodéfense celle-là est dénoncée dans
le roman ainsi que dans le film car
c'est là le côté science fiction
anticipation du sujet et qui disent on
pourrait amener à une insécurité sociale
et bien andré rolland nous vous
remercions j'espère que ce film et ce
livre auront beaucoup de succès comme
vous pouvez le constater nous nous
trouvons en ce moment même dans l'espace
en route vers la constellation d'orion à
plus de 15 cents années lumière de la
terre
alors comment sommes nous arrivés
jusqu'ici et bien c'est tout simplement
au aux auteurs de science-fiction à nous
répondre
c'est pourquoi nous allons ouvrir le
premier dossier de temps x avec ce qui
est le plus ancien thème de science
fiction
un thème que nous avons introduit avec
jules verne
herbert george wells mais que d'autres
avantages comme cyrano de bergerac ou
encore jonathan swift avait exploré il
s'agit de voyages dans l'espace que nous
allons maintenant découvrir
[Musique]
hier la science demain la fiction
aujourd'hui la science fiction
souvenez vous il y a dix ans à peine
le mot était encore pratiquement inconnu
en france et aujourd'hui on le rencontre
partout dans la littérature bien sûr
mais aussi dans le cinéma la bande
dessinée les arts graphiques
l'expression musicale mais savons-nous
vraiment ce qu'est cette fameuse science
fiction on croit trop souvent hélas qu
elle a pour but à travers des histoires
simples est de martial berthe hommes de
nous faire découvrir certains aspects du
monde de demain nous pensons que la
science fiction est bien plus que cela
c'est avant tout un autre regard sur
notre réalité le voyage sans fin dans
les mystères du temps et de l'espace et
de l'homme alors pour mieux savoir quel
est le véritable univers de la science
fiction
pardon sans plus attendre en voyage dans
notre plus loin d'un passé
[Musique]
il y à 15 milliards d'années la matière
de l'univers concentré dans un espace de
quelques kilomètres a soudain explosé
donnant naissance aux étoiles et aux
planètes sept planètes bouillonnante
déchiré par les volcans est noyé sous le
feu liquide c'est la terre il ya 4
milliards d'années peu un peu se sont
formés les maires et les continents
primitive
[Musique]
et un beau jeu sans que l'on sache
encore pourquoi les êtres vivants ont
jailli de ce monde en plusieurs
[Musique]
oui
la vie s'est d'abord développée dans les
océans jusqu'à ce qu'apparaissent sur
terre et dans les airs et reptiles
géants de l'ère secondaire
bien avant la naissance de l'homme ces
animaux fabuleux ont été les maîtres du
monde pendant 100 millions d'années
[Musique]
soudain la terre change à nouveau de
visage un drôle de sages à un jour
l'idée de tailler des cailloux mais avec
lui commence l'histoire de l'humanite
cette histoire où le rat très lentement
pendant des millénaires
jusqu'à ce qu'un coup de théâtre
viennent encore une fois bouleversé la
face du monde
il y un peu plus d'un siècle de cela
l'homme s'est soudain mise à inventer
des machines
si nous nous posons maintenant la
question de savoir ce que sont ses
machines ses inventions extraordinaires
qui semble parfois tout droit issus de
quelques romans de jules verne
eh bien nous diront qu avant tout ce
sont des rêves des fictions qui grâce à
un savant à l'ingénieur sont tout à coup
devenu réalité
imaginez un peu la surprise du président
de l'époque
lorsqu'un beau matin de 1771 il dira
passer sous leurs fenêtres c'est énorme
char ventru qui crachait vapeur et fumé
miracles
l'engin avancer sans qu' aucun cheval ne
soit là pour le tirer la civilisation
venait de faire son entrée dans une ère
nouvelle
bien sûr l'apparition de ces engins
stupéfiants provoqua au début des
réactions assez insolites ainsi persuadé
qu'elle était mue par la magie les
hommes de la rue se prosternèrent devant
les premières voitures
de leur côté les savants déclarèrent que
de toute façon ces voitures n'auraient
aucun avenir puisque leurs pilotes ne
pourrait jamais supporter des vitesses
supérieures à 40 kilomètres à l'heure
[Musique]
tournons nous maintenant vers cette
gigantesque chauve souris apple quoi
l'homme allait voler là dedans
dans cet engin possible n'oublions pas
que nous sommes en 1890 après tout
quelle différence y at-il entre cet
engin pour le moins étrange et le
gypaète ce gigantesque navire volant
imaginé par jules verne la même année et
pourtant par un beau soir d'octobre
la chauve souris à vapeur décolle à
nouveau aux côtés d' inventions tout
aussi prodigieuse comme l'ampoulé
électrique ou le téléphone
le merveilleux scientifique comme on
disait à l'époque devenait réalité au
niveau du 20ème siècle par exemple par
agen de savants du nom d'albert einstein
ose écrire cette chose absolument
impensable
l'énergie d'un corps est égal à sa masse
multipliée par le carré de la vitesse de
la lumière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
e égal mck cette fameuse équation
universel qu'il est honnête en trop un
secret l'énergie atomique
[Musique]
ni
mais
[Musique]
sait-on que le principe de la bombe
atomique a été minutieusement décrits
dans un texte lu science fiction dès le
mois de mars 1944
sait-on que le terme astronautes qui a
été forgé par un auteur français rosny
aîné et le mot télévision par un auteur
américain hugo games pas là où passent
les imaginaires reste parfois le nouveau
et si maintenant à notre tour tout comme
jules verne à son époque nous faisions
aussi de la science fiction
afin de découvrir où peut bien nous
mener ce progrès
[Musique]
imaginons qui nous sera possible de
voyager dans l'espace
l'étoile étoiles jusqu'aux confins de
l'univers et d'y rencontrer des
civilisations extraterrestres tactique
note les autres imaginons aussi nous
soyons secondes et dans toutes nos
tâches par des robots et que des
cerveaux électronique l'incroyable
puissance résonne notre place les
problèmes les plus complexes
imaginons enfin que nous ayons maîtriser
le problème du vieillissement et de la
main que nous ayons aussi développé en
août les super pouvoirs qui ferait de
nous ce qu'on appelle des surhommes tous
là aujourd'hui c'est encore de la
science physique mais c'est aussi
peut-être la réalité 2 go
[Musique]
et oui un film qui nous a menés aux
confins des étoiles et qui est signé je
le rappelle jean claude arié alors
jean-pierre petit d'abord bonjour je
vous rappelle je me rappelle à tout le
monde que vous êtes physicien et que
d'autre part vous êtes un passionné de
science fiction alors la question est
celle ci est ce qu'il faut être
passionné de science fiction pour
admettre la possibilité d'aller un jour
vers les étoiles bien ce voyage vers les
autres étoiles de science fiction le
pose un problème de l'association pose
est est-ce que c'est un problème qui
peut devenir un problème scientifique ça
c'est une question qu'on qu'on peut se
demander
première chose qui vous préciser
rapidement
nous sommes entrés dans une ère spatiale
nous savons aller vers d'autres planètes
vers la lune nous avons vis des hommes
dans la lune nous avons envoyé des
sondes spatiales dans vénus nous allons
envoyer d'autres sondes vers pluton
mais tout ça c'est une proche banlieue
et la distance qui nous sépare d'autres
systèmes planétaires possible d'autres
étoiles notre soleil sont absolument
considérable on pourrait dire qu'il
s'agit de distance qui sont dix mille
fois cent mille fois mille fois un
million de fois plus grande et on peut
chiffrer sa très rapidement grâce à la
lumière à il faut huit minutes pour que
la lumière du soleil nous parviennent de
même pour que la lumière de la plus
proche étoiles
vienne jusqu'à nous il faut plus de
quatre ans par conséquent nous vivons
dans une physique on est enfermé dans
cette vitesse maximale la lumière et un
voyage vers une autre étoile ça nous
coûterait 8 ans notre vie par est ce que
ça veut dire que tout ce qu'ils écrivent
les auteurs de science-fiction n'aura
aucune chance de se réaliser dans
l'avenir
mais la science fiction c'est un petit
peu l'école buissonnière de la science
est elle elle saute carrément le pas on
doit pouvoir trouver une autre solution
oui comme nous l'avons vu tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs dans le petit film les
auteurs de science fiction ne se prive
pas d'imaginer d'autres moyens en
particulier l'hyperespace les hypers
univers et c'est oui
alors actuellement notre physique est
pas prête et pas équipés pour envisager
des choses comme ça les mathématiques
sont déjà beaucoup plus à même
d'envisager des mes problèmes de genre
et puis dix puis à ce poste c'est quand
même une question qui datent beaucoup
plus longtemps que ça et les philosophes
ont été les premiers à dire que
l'univers avait peut-être une structure
est plus riche que celle que nous
percevions est précisément à ce que les
auteurs de science fiction ne nous amène
pas à réviser nos conceptions sur
l'univers mais en tout cas il pose le
problème ce qui est déjà mérite parce
que finalement la science ne se l'est
pas posé officiellement on peut se
demander d'ailleurs est ce que c'est un
problème qui de notre époque
est ce que est ce qu'on a tort d'être
impatient est ce que est ce qu'il ya
dans la science fiction des valeurs
récupérables pour le scientifique
il ya surtout cette question ce problème
posé de la communication avec d'autres
mondes
et c'est peut-être un problème que les
individus or le courage exposé bien
espérons que les auteurs de
science-fiction leur donnera ce courage
en attendant et bien pour tous ceux qui
veulent se familiariser avec le voyage
dans l'espace
je propose deux ouvrages des ouvrages
fondamentaux qu'il faut avoir lu le
premier histoire de cosmonaute paru aux
éditions du livre de poche c'est un
recueil signé des maîtres yoaké me dise
un excellent recueil de très bonnes
nouvelles américaines
d'autre part eh bien
toujours
dans le domaine du voyage dans l'espace
je recommande rendez vous avec rama
d'arthur clark c'est un très grand livre
qui a obtenu le prix hugo il ya quelques
années et qui vous proposera je crois de
voyage est aussi très loin à travers ces
lignes alors tout de suite revenons sur
terre
je me tourne maintenant vers igor que je
crois il a une communication importante
à vous faire oui en effet nous savons
que vous êtes très nombreux à vous poser
toutes sortes de questions en ce qui
concerne la science fiction et nous
devons penser à temps x qu'il était
nécessaire de vous donner une
ambassadrice alors tout de suite je me
tourne vers chantal de farsi qui sera
cette ambassadrice vous la voyez
maintenant sur votre écran et j'aimerais
lui demander comment cela va se passer
cette séquence courrier vient mon rôle
va consister tout d'abord à répondre à
votre courrier alors je pense recevoir
des lettres ont suscité en moi je
répondrai à vos questions donc par écrit
alors je n'aurais peut-être pas le temps
de répondre à toutes vos lettres parce
que je l'espère très nombreuses mais en
tout cas soyez sûr que je les lirai avec
la plus grande attention je
sélectionnerais les plus intéressantes
et je répondrai cette fois en direct à
l'antenne à vos questions et je leur
donnerai toutes sortes d'informations
en bref tu feras deux des spécialistes
de la science fiction un peu de temps
voilà alors n'hésitez pas écrivez moi à
temps x tf1 bureau 4071 17 rue de
l'arrivée
paris 15e merci championnat x est
maintenant terminée nous revenons en
la semaine prochaine nous repartirons et
cette fois à la conquête des autres
mondes des autres planètes aux confins
de l'univers
en attendant il ne reste plus qu'à vous
souhaiter au revoir et comme on dit dans
le grand en langage galactique à tram
[Musique]